et 130 candidats en lice pour cette
19ème édition du challenge des créateurs
des chefs d'entreprise qui ont à coeur
de défendre leurs activités et leur
savoir faire
ils ont envie le dossier ce cas me
représente donc on va avoir envie de se
faire connaître
on a envie d'élargir son réseau on a
envie aussi barre de montrer ce conflit
on est quand même contents de ce qu'on
fait on lance le l'esprit de caste une
édition 12 jury constitué d'experts en
création d'entreprise vont auditionner
tous les candidats un speed casting de
huit minutes pour faire la différence et
être sélectionné parmi les finalistes
quand on dit que le réunionnais n'a pas
d'idée c'est faux moi je trouve qu'au
contraire on a une base d'idées on a
beaucoup de valeur on a beaucoup
d'humanité on a beaucoup de choses qui
sont mises en valeur et c'est l'occasion
de découvrir ces jeunes talents cette
année particulièrement on a des projets
innovants en termes vraiment donc
d'idées nouvelles de développement
durable et de technologie
à la fin de ce speed testing ils ne sont
plus que douze 12 finalistes qui vont
devoir défendre leur projet dans les six
catégories récompensées par le challenge
des créateurs
prochaine étape les battles à suivre sur
réunion 1ère ils 9 7 4 tv